the jurogan experience well you're not
just the ufc champion you're one of the
best champions it's very it's very
unique to watch you fight because you're
you're one of those people
like anderson silva in his prime where
you've kind of cleaned out your division
you know and there's no disrespect to
your opponents but some of your
opponents when i'm watching you fight
them i'm not thinking are they going to
beat you i'm thinking what are you going
to do to them
that's it's a strange position to be in
where you're almost like competing
you're competing against these women
but your
level is so much higher than everyone
else in this 125 pound division that
there's just not much there for you in
terms of like valentina has to fight
this woman there's no fight like that
for you
i think that um definitely this is one
of my goals in my uh performance in my
training and um
definitely is this is like
what i uh
the idea of my fight style
to be able to
win the fight
made the fight
very beautiful from the technical side
very intensive very like
just high level martial art but in the
same time without do it like dirty fight
like street fight just like different
level when you can finish your opponent
without
them touch you so this is kind of like
like ideally idea
ideal
well you can see how you sometimes
impose the opponent's style on them
it's almost like you're challenging
yourself like the jessica andraj fight
like in the coming of that fight most
people thought the only way
she would have any sort of advantage at
all would possibly be grappling and so
what did you do you outgrappled there
like did you do that on purpose no no no
no
i don't know this is what i think it's
no
because uh maybe
people just like was speaking about that
so much so frequently before the fight
maybe it's just stay in my like mind and
was there but you know i never felt that
this is a position dangerous for me
since the beginning since they're like i
i know exactly uh
what is my strengths i know exactly what
is my power um
that's why it never was a doubt
would i be good there no
i know what i can i know exactly uh what
i have to be worried about what i have
to worry about um
in the fight i had i know that i have to
be careful like to see everything
because it's mma everything can happen
you cannot just go there and say okay
i'm a champion everyone has to fall down
no you cannot you ca you have to
be wild you have to be like a wild
animal ready for anything and but in the
same time
you just
you cannot overestimate your opponent
because you are overestimate them
it's gonna be like not interesting fight
you're gonna be like uh just
afraid of throwing anything
and that's why it's you have to find the
balance and the balance is everything
where you are um
like
you can do whatever without any fear but
in the same time very careful
and um
i know i never before the fight put some
like challenges
for me
would i be good there would i be good
like what i do
like for the my next fight i train
myself
for the different situation and this is
what we are working like and it's not
just my work it's uh like teamwork pavel
antonina we all watching our opponents
and we share what we think about them
what we have to be worried what we have
to work on and through our training
camps through trainings we just work on
every possible situation and even for
example i saw some situation in the
fight what's happening like not with my
opponent or like different completely
different fight and we tried this
situation we uh we try what how i will
what i will do how i would escape or how
i will finish from this situation so we
just
getting ready for anything and this is
what i think helped me to
take right decision during the fight
because i don't have time to think about
what i will do next what my technique
will be next in the fight it's
everything happened like instantly and i
have to be sure that my brain and my
body ready to act
well it's very clear that you have a
very well-rounded skill set but it's
also clear that when you're faced with
particular challenges your preparation
for those particular challenges almost
puts you in a situation where you want
to try
like the julianna pena fight is a good
example that right like you shocked the
world when you arm barred her ever
because everybody felt like if she had a
chance to beat you it would be grappling
and you as a muay thai champion if you
had a chance to beat her would be your
striking but then when you submitted her
everybody was like holy [ __ ] like that
was a wake-up call for a lot of people
that you're not just well-rounded but
you are capable of finishing everywhere
that you're lethal everywhere
yeah this is what uh every time was in
my training my goals for the competition
uh not just go there and compete
but um go there and win
doesn't matter what i have to do to win
the fight i have to find the solution i
have to find the way to win the fight
and every time it was like my mindset
i'm i don't like like um this idea just
go and have fun in the fight i don't
like idea just be there and like
just to experience the feeling i think
for someone it's good but if you have
like higher goals for yourself you have
to put higher goals like higher like
things what you're thinking for this is
in my head this is what i had since the
beginning that uh
no matter what happening i have to find
solution to turn the fight to my side
and wins the fight and
definitely i was like i understood
fighting in mixed martial arts i have to
have more arms i have to have more
advantages like um
if we are comparing with the uh other
fighter because uh more advantage you
have it's kind of like um in the war
right
you have a handgun you have like a
certain like percentage to win you have
like uh more like arms in your like
position you have more percentages so i
want to have like 100 percent and uh
percentage to be in the fight that's why
i was training like everything and
like training
not just
pretend to do technique but know how to
make people tap after this technique
yeah so when you say more arms you mean
more weapons right exactly
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify